what's up lovely people my name is Jess
McDonald it's the second of junior
watching games but news and this isn't
assets actually it's not even semi yeah
the corn dollars here Marcus's head of
Xbox and possible savior of the xbox one
Phil Spencer has said more things to
knock up our approval rating of him
today by saying he wants to push PC
gaming back into the foreground
Microsoft's recent acquisition of the
rise of the nation's franchise is set to
be just the beginning of the company
firming up there hold on to pc gaming
replying to somebody on twitter Spencer
said I am worried that my stuff needs to
up our gaming presents for Windows part
of my role that xbox is to bring back
our windows gaming focus let me know
what you want to see mark soft work on
in the PC gaming space this month xbox
is giving you Dark Souls for free that's
totally free so long as you have xbox
live gold as a result of its one-year
anniversary games with gold is cramming
in an extra free Xbox 360 game with its
usual allotment of two which makes it
three free games the other titles
offered up include Charlie murder and
super street fighter 4 arcade edition if
you have your eye on dark souls look out
for it up until june 15 which is when
the other two games will become
available right till the end of the
month a little while ago Nintendo said
they reckoned that Mario Kart 8 were
going to help sell we use and it turns
out there were on the right track with
that one in fact the racing titles
featuring gorillas and babies driving
high power death mobiles has helped wii
u sales in the UK climbed the impressive
albeit slightly demonic figure of six
hundred and sixty-six percent the data
was revealed by UK tracking company GF
k-chart track and included the tidbit
that eighty-two percent of all the mario
kart 8 sales in the UK came through the
mario kart 8 bundle the game has also
had the best first week of sales for any
Wii U game since its launch in the UK in
2012 and as our last story of the day
Mortal Kombat ten is coming to satisfy
all of your wildly inappropriate ultra
violent and ass-kicking cravings Warner
Brothers announced that the game is
coming
PC as well as microsoft and sony's lost
and current generation consoles they're
promising the most brutal combat
experience ever that's combat with a
cave and players will get to experience
ex-assistant online contest where every
fighter matters in a global battle for
supremacy there's also going to be
multiple character variations available
for the first time ever and an original
story which is set to showcase
characters like scorpion and sub-zero's
let me know if you're keen to get your
gory x-ray vision on in that commenting
section below and as an added bonus let
me know whether you think Mortal Kombat
is too violent or just awesome those are
all the things that I want to tell you
about today but I'll have some more
newsy goodness for you same time
tomorrow so be sure to check back with
me then push me slower we're on a budget
everything's packed for e3